down with communism that's the message
from citizens in cuba as many have taken
to the streets to protest the government
thanks for joining us at 11 i'm denise
faldis and i'm brian loftis these are
the large protests on the island in
decades as cubans complain about the
lack of food the lack of medicine
the country facing a crisis aggravated
by the covid pandemic
protests have spilled onto the streets
really all over the world including las
vegas boulevard
orco mana is on the strip tonight with
their message denise and brian hundreds
of people took to the las vegas trip
tonight
to stand in solidarity with the
protesters in cuba
for them this is all about showing their
support and also calling on the u.s
government to take action
around three to four hundred protesters
marched along the las vegas strip
tuesday night they started at the
boulevard in sahara and made their way
south many were holding cuban flags and
also signs
saying sos cuba some protesters drove
down the strip in their cars
too this is all in solidarity with the
recent unrest in cuba
resulting in the largest protests we've
seen in that country in decades
protesters there are fighting against
the communist regime which they say has
oppressed them for decades
but their calls for justice this time
around have been triggered
by food shortages rising prices and the
cuban government's response to rising
covenanting infections
now communities across the u.s including
here in las vegas have taken to the
streets
protesters we spoke to say they felt
compelled to speak out
i think it's very important for our
voice to be heard
since we are such a big country the more
we go out
the better it is if cuba is on the
streets
we can be on the streets as well we need
everybody to open their eyes
because the reality is that
we're hurting a lot protesters are also
calling on the u.s government to
intervene to help the people of cuba
president biden released a statement
monday saying in part
quote the united states calls on the
cuban regime to hear their people
and serve their needs at this vital
moment end quote but it's unclear if any
policy changes relating to cuba
will be on the horizon
metro police police officers were
following along with the protesters
as they marched south on this strip to
make sure people stayed safe
and it appears everything remained
peaceful tonight reporting live on the
las vegas strip orca mana 8 news now